in this video we're going to talk about
what is one of the darkest chapters in
human history
the holocaust which involved the
massacre of roughly 6 million jews
and as many as 11 million civilians in
total
in order to understand the holocaust
we're going to start at world war one
even prior to world war one there were
massacres especially of jews in places
like the russian empire
the term pogrom is a russian word
meaning these violent
riots or attacks on people for their
ethnicity and there were
several through the 19th century but
they go back even before that word was
coined
as early as the first crusades famously
in the rhineland
many of the jewish people were killed
and attacked
and you had a solid thread of
anti-semitism
throughout much of europe including
germany
and eastern europe as we get up to and
through world war one now as we've
talked about in other videos
the central powers lose world war one
and the treaty of versailles
places a lot of the blame on germany the
national pride of germany has been
shattered they have
lost this war they have lost territory
their economy is in shambles they're
paying reparations
and it is in that context that the
national
socialist party forms officially in 1920
coming out of the german workers party
they focused on ideas of national
identity
and from the start were against ethnic
groups
blaming their problems including the
loss of world war one often
on these ethnic groups in 1921
hitler who had fought during world war
one and based on some of his writings
seem to have found a lot of meaning
during the war
he becomes the national socialist party
leader national socialist
it gets abbreviated as nazi national
socialist
party nazi party in 1923
hitler tries to begin an overthrow of
the government
but his push his coup is unsuccessful
and he is imprisoned and it is while in
prison
that he writes down his belief system
that eventually gets published
upon his release in 1925 under the title
mineconf which can be translated as my
struggle
or my battle this is just an excerpt
from mein kampf
if we pass all the causes of the german
collapse in review
the ultimate and most decisive remains
the failure to recognize the racial
problem
and especially the jewish menace the
defeats on the battlefield in august
1918 so he's referring to the end of
world war one
would have been child's play to bear
they stood in no
proportion to the victories of our
people
it was not they that caused our downfall
no
it was brought about by that power which
prepared these defeats by systematically
over many decades
robbing our people of the political and
moral
instincts and forces which alone make
nations capable and hence worthy of
existence
he's blaming germany's defeat in world
war one on a relatively small
ethnic group so as you can see a very
twisted mind very twisted thinking
the lost purity of the blood alone
destroys
inner happiness forever so he's very
caught up with these ideas of purity
plunges man into the abyss for all time
and the consequences can never
more be eliminated from body and spirit
over time what starts off as this fringe
leader of a fringe party as we go into
the 20s and as the german economy gets
even worse and there's hyperinflation
more and more people start to throw
their support behind these extremists
and as we go into the 30s
the national socialist party is actually
able to get
reasonable representation in the german
parliament
and in 1933 the president of germany
gives appoints hitler to be chancellor
which is equivalent of being
prime minister despite the nazis not
having a majority
in parliament this is the official
beginning of what the nazis will call
the third reich reich translates as
realm they considered
the first reich to be the holy roman
empire they refer to the second
reich as the german empire after the
holy roman empire
up and through world war one they don't
consider
the weimar republic which they hate the
third reich they consider that the
interim reich
and they consider themselves the third
reich the
heir to the german empire and the holy
roman empire
once hitler and the nazis get power they
really get a stranglehold on it
they start persecuting their political
opponents
both outside the party and inside the
party
and they also start to take action on
these
twisted ideas hitler expressed in mein
kampf
in 1935 they are able to pass the
nuremberg laws
which strips german jews of their
citizenship
it forbids intermarrying between
non-jewish germans
and jews this is only one of many steps
that will continue to demean the rights
of jews inside of germany
in 1938 you have what is known as
crystal knocked or the night of broken
glass
hundreds of synagogues are burned
thousands of jewish businesses are
destroyed
and many jews are killed in that night
then as we get into 1939 hitler's
armies famously invade poland beginning
what many historians consider be the
start of world war ii
what would eventually be known as the
holocaust
goes into full effect in 1941.
jews are sometimes executed in the
streets in their homes
many of them are captured and sent to
concentration camps
to get a sense of the scale of this
operation we have this excerpt from
michael barenbaum's book the world must
know
the policy of extermination involved
every level of german society
and marshaled the entire apparatus of
the german bureaucracy
parish churches and the interior
ministry supplied the birth records that
defined and
isolated jews the post office delivered
the notifications of definition
expropriation denaturalization and
deportation
the finance ministry confiscated jewish
wealth and property
german industrial and commercial firms
fired jewish workers
officers and board members even
disenfranchising jewish stockholders
the universities refused to admit jewish
students denied degrees to those already
enrolled
and dismissed jewish faculty government
transportation bureaus handled the
billing arrangements with the railroads
for the trains that
carry jews to their death and so the
point that's being made here is this
could not be done
just with hitler and some of his close
associates
to kill millions of people on this scale
you needed
an entire apparatus and hundreds of
thousands
if not millions of people were involved
in some way
and at least several hundreds of
thousands of people within germany must
have been aware
of what was happening
needless to say the death toll was
considerable this here is a visual
depiction
of the percentage of the jewish
population that was killed in various
regions
and as you can see 80 to 90 percent of
the jewish population in germany
czechoslovakia poland was killed
during the holocaust in the territories
occupied by
germany in russia during world war ii
almost as many have been killed
in france italy a fifth to a quarter of
the population was killed
to put things more in human terms this
is a picture of children
who were in in auschwitz one of the most
infamous concentration camps
and you can see their names their ages
and then when they were killed
historians believe five to six million
jews were killed during the holocaust
including
a million and a half children this was
two-thirds of the jewish population of
europe
but the holocaust went further it's
believed that over 10 million civilians
were killed during the holocaust
through over 3 million prisoners of war
were killed
and other people including several
hundred thousand romani often referred
to as gypsies
several hundred thousand people with
disabilities many thousands of
homosexuals
were all put to death during the
holocaust
now we've covered a lot of world history
and a lot of it
unfortunately has a lot of death a lot
of destruction
and sometimes targeting people for their
ethnicity but
never in world history have we seen
something at this
scale and because it seemed to be a
relatively new
concept a term was coined genocide
it was coined by rafael lemkin who was a
holocaust survivor had 49 members of his
family killed during the holocaust and
it means
killing of a people geno coming from a
people
or family and side killing but maybe
even more interesting than the
word definition itself is thinking about
why this
actually happened and maybe even more
importantly how
society can avoid it i'll leave you with
that question
what do you think was the reason why
this happened and do you think we have a
risk of that happening in the future and
how can we prevent it